- I have to apologize.
I ran late today.
I was perfectly fine coming downstairs
and was like, I felt funky,
so I sprayed perfume.
- [Rob] In your eye?
- And, sprayed it directly in my eyeball.
And, it's not good.
- Gee, your eye smells delicious.
- I know, it's burns so badly.
Have you ever?
I've never done that.
- Oh yeah, I did.
I was doing a play in London once
and they were doing my hair
and somebody called me.
I turned around and got
a full shot of hairspray
in both eyes.
- Oh.
- Not good.
- I gotta be honest, I've had hairspray
because of that kind of similar situation.
Perfume sucks.
- Is way worse.
You look though, I don't
notice a difference.
You look great, she looks great.
- Do you wanna smell me?
- That's a sexy eye.
- You've done a lot of interviews.
I mean, God for so many years.
So what, do you remember your first one?
I think you were really young, right?
- Yeah, oh, I remember my first one
just because I still
laugh at the headline.
It was in the Dayton Daily News in Ohio.
I was living in Ohio.
And how about this?
Weird hell.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're so cute.
- Oh, there is is.
Boy, 12, sets his cap for stardom.
- Sets his cap for stardom?
- I just set my cap and off I went.
- It sounds straight up out of the 50s.
- Doesn't it?
It's like really insane.
- Sets his cap, gee, golly.
- I know, I was so proud of that.
You would've thought that was the cover
of Time Magazine for me.
- Oh no, I wasn't that young,
but I did like, I don't know,
like junior high do something for singing
and you'd thought I'd won a Grammy.
- [Rob] Oh, for sure.
- I was in the Burleson Star
and I was like, I've made it.
- And, I kept it.
My parents have 5,000 copies of it.
- That's awesome though.
It's like the first thing you do
that inspired you to keep going.
It's fun.
- It's really fun.
- You knew you wanted to
be an actor very young.
I didn't know I wanted to be a singer
until I was teenager.
- I was eight when I knew.
Just because I went and saw a
local in Dayton, production,
like literally a neighborhood
playhouse production of Oliver
and there were kids in it.
And, like the light went off for me
and I knew that but at
a serious, serious level
where all the other kids
thought I was like a freak
'cause I was dead serious.
- Well, you have kids and I have kids.
I have an eight year
old actually right now
and I can't imagine her just being like,
this is it right now.
- [Rob] Can you imagine?
- No.
- You'd be like,
"Honey, you have your
whole life ahead of you.
"You're gonna learn about so many things."
- But you knew.
- I was like, shut up,
I'm gonna be an actor.
(laughing)
- Bold.
- Yeah.
- So, I hear you had a
memorable moment though
with a famous musician.
This is the craziest story ever.
So, it's right after you got sober, right?
- Oh, I know, yes.
So, on my podcast, Literally,
one of the things that I love
is I get to not only just talk
to people like Chris Pratt
and Gwyneth, and Oprah
and just the biggies.
But I also get to talk to people
that I get to nerd out
to that I don't know.
Like Jann Wenner created
the Rolling Stone.
He has a book out that's great.
I had him on and I was
talking about when I got,
we're both sober, Jann and I.
I got sober 32 years ago.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- Thanks.
- That's so awesome, yeah.
Here's another gee, golly.
- I set my cap and I got sober.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Nice callback.
- That's right, yeah.
And so, I was newly sober.
And, I was backstage at
a Rolling Stones concert
and Keith Richards said,
"Won't you come back to the
hotel and party with me later?"
And, I was like,
okay, I'm either gonna
party with Keith Richards
and not be sober
or I'm gonna turn down Keith
Richards to go party with?
I'm 20, whatever it is.
And I remember, I didn't do it,
but it was like one of those.
- Good for you 'cause that's hard
because you know what though?
If you turned down something that rad,
you knew that you needed to
make a change in your life.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- You know that,
you know what I'm saying?
- And, that's actually a good point.
- I felt really good.
I felt like if I could do that
then I was gonna be.
(audience applause)
- I always get worried about stuff.
I've been invited to certain things
and I'm just not like that rad.
I'm like, I can't hang with people.
So, I'm like, oh, I'm busy.
I always say I'm busy
'cause I'm nervous in those environments.
- You have celebrity intimidation factor?
- It's not so much that.
I think that maybe yes
because I feel like everybody feels like
we're all at some barbecue
and we all know each other
and we all are supposed to
have everything in common.
And I'm like, what?
We all have separate friends
outside of this world.
I know it's weird.
- No, it's true.
- And I'm like, we're all
not cool and we're gonna die.
It's like build a bridge and get over it.
It's like we're all not that cool.
- Truth.
- All right, We just saw a clip
from your new Netflix movie Dog Gone.
So it's based on a true story, right?
- Yes.
- And this story breaks my heart
'cause I have a similar story.
Not completely similar,
but I've lost a dog.
- Ugh, It's the worst.
I mean anybody who has lost,
like, literally, where is my dog?
It was here a minute
ago and now it's gone.
It's a true story about a family
who's having their own issues
and their beloved pet gets
lost on the Appalachian trail
and father and son who don't get along
are forced to go on this adventure
to try to find this dog.
And you'll cry your eyes out.
- I cry all the time.
- It's super, it is the
best feel good movie
I've been a part of in a long, long time.
I'm super happy with it.
- I love that for you.
Just as a project in general,
to feel that kind of like--
- And it's got dogs, come on.
- Yeah, but I also feel
like it's based on a true story, right?
So it's like I sometimes
feel like life is like that.
Like things happen that are just tragic
to bring people together because
that is kind of interesting
that you said the father and
son weren't really relating.
It wasn't adding up for them, right?
And then by the end I
assume like, you know.
- They understand each other better.
And I have to say, because I know
a lot of people said,
"I wanna see that movie,
"but I'm not watching
it if that dog dies."
- [Kelly] Old Yeller,
it's like killed us all.
- Dog does not die.
I know that's like in theory spoiler,
but it isn't.
I've ran into way too
many people who are like,
"I'm not watching it
if I even get a whiff."
- Because we all saw
Old Yeller as children
and it was dramatic.
- Oh When The Red Fern Grows.
- [Kelly] When The Red Fern,
or Where The Red Fern Grows.
- Where The Red Fern, woo.
- But when too, both questions.
But do you remember the
first dog you ever had?
You're a dog person.
You have like a couple dogs right?
- Yeah, I have four dogs.
- [Kelly] Oh, you have four dogs?
- I have four dogs.
- [Kelly] I have two.
That's a lot, four dogs.
Oh, look at that love.
- [Rob] That's Daisy.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, that's Owen,
the big dog and Daisy.
And sometimes I just go in
and I just cuddle up with them.
They come into my bed
sometimes I go to their beds.
- It's interesting though, dogs know.
I was having like a really hard time
and I hadn't slept alone in years,
and my dog, who never was
allowed to be in the bed,
literally crawled up,
and he like got right beside me
and I just snuggled with him.
And he knew.
That's why I like animals
better than humans,
yeah, most times.
- I'm down with that.
- I mean, you're great,
but I just mean like,
but most times animals
are just really awesome.
You mentioned happy tears
though at the end of Dog Gone,
Which is awesome.
We need that.
So what's the first movie
that made you like ugly cry?
- Oh, for sure Brian's Song.
It's going way back.
- Oh my God, I know that.
- And I have a theory that
every man of a certain age
without a doubt,
first time they cry was
watching Brian Song.
'Cause it's a manly movie
and it's about football.
(howling)
- And that was like, I
think Rudy for me too.
- Oh, Rudy's great.
- Rudy, yeah at the end.
I don't know, yeah,
- Rudy is great.
There's so many.
I love those kinds of
movies and as you know,
they don't get made so much anymore.
- They don't.
I don't know, I sometimes feel
like life is serious enough.
I do want to feel good.
So, please make more of these movies.
I like to go to the movie
theater and believe--
- Everybody watch Dog Gone
and we'll make more of them.
- It is sad though, losing your dog.
I'm like, oh, I love the happy ending,
and I love that it's not a spoiler alert.
We need that feel good thing.
But Dog Gone is is also the story
of a father and son, like you mentioned.
So you've got two boys.
Do you guys bond a lot?
How do you bond?
- We bond a lot.
I'm really lucky.
I'm very close to them.
We, ski together.
- You're like the coolest
family in the, what the hell?
- There's my boys.
There they are.
- I'm trying to keep up
with 'em, it's tough.
It's tough to keep up with those abs,
but I'm trying.
I have a new show on Netflix
coming we'll talk about,
but it's a few months off
that I co-created with my son John Owen.
- My son Matthew, he's
in the finance world.
So now I'm really like learning
about their work lives.
It's a whole different phase
where you get them through childhood
then all of a sudden
it's like, how's work?
It's super cool.
- I know I have friends
that have older kids
and it's just like,
it almost becomes like a
different kind of friendship
with your kid.
Like, because they're now out of your home
and making poor decisions
all on their own.
- That you don't know about anymore.
they're not at home.
- And you know, you know
what, don't tell me.
Unless I need to know or
you need to get out of jail.
So is it true that you
once scared them though
on a camping trip?
'Cause this is traumatic.
- Yeah, so we went camping.
They were probably eight and six,
and I would always tell
them stories about Bigfoot.
And so I decided we were
going to the Pacific Northwest
where Bigfoot supposedly lives.
So I rented a really
elaborate Bigfoot costume
and I hid it in the Winnebago
that we were driving.
And then I hopped out in
the middle of the night
and walked around the
campfire in the distance
making like horrible noises.
It was really, it was so sick.
It was the best.
- My kids are six and eight.
They would never sleep again.
- Well one of 'em, Matthew,
came up and he kicked
me in the you know what.
- That's bold.
- This kid's gonna grow up to be somebody.
- Yeah, what'd the other one do?
- He vomited.
(laughing)
- It's like, no, they are in crisis.
- That's right.
Fight or flight.
- Yeah, I love that one.
And you said that costume was over, like.
- Yeah, well the problem
was I hadn't tried it on.
I just stupidly assumed it would fit.
And so when I put it on
the eye holes were up here,
and I was like, ah!
- Probably looked more scary.
- 'Cause I was staggering.
- Yeah, until you were
kicked in that, by your son.
(laughing)
- It was definitely a
family highlight for sure.
- That's amazing oh my God.
I'm afraid to scare my children
'cause I don't want them
to sleep with me forever.
I already have to be like,
"Go to your own room."
How did your wife feel when you told her
that you scared your
tiny children like that?
Was she laughing or?
- I'm trying to think if
she was in on it or not.
- Oh, okay.
- I think I kind of told
her I was gonna do it.
But I don't think she
really thought it through.
She's too busy doing mom things.
And I think when it happened,
my memory of it, she wasn't a fan.
(laughing)
- It's 'cause she didn't
wanna sleep with 'em either.
So we need another break.
You can see Rob in Gog Gone on Netflix now
and in 9-1-1 Lone Star, which
returns to Fox on January 24.